the elephant in the room but walking
dead obviously is the biggest
one of the biggest things that ever hit
television it's uh i know i watched
through the first
uh five seasons and uh you know it was a
movie every week it felt like i was
watching a freaking movie
and that's how i explain it i'd say it's
like i love horror i'm a huge horror fan
as everyone knows
and i go i'd be a zombie for a day i
remember even i
actually read for something in it a
while back but i remember i just loved
that show and when your character
i will tell you this there's a couple of
characters on the show they're all
really good actors
but when your character came on there
was something just
i i could just smell your character
there's just something
just real about him just really grounded
and
got a little dirt you know a little
dirty and
i don't know i just really love i mean i
know a lot of people loved abraham
and yeah it was such a great character
to watch and
did you first of all when when you got
this did they say hey this is just for a
recurring
and then all of a sudden this thing blew
up and you're like holy [ __ ] i i just
lasted a couple seasons here
how many seasons did you do four came in
the middle of four
uh season four and then did all of five
all of six
and then uh the beginning of the end of
seven right right right so
you know in in in walking dead math
that's actually three and a half seasons
because
even when you know there was twenty when
i was there there's 22 regulars
22 regulars over 16 episodes you would
do maybe
five or six episodes some years
um so my first year when i did four
even though i was get i was guessing uh
that
you know that's basically just shy
of what some people were doing every you
know for a season that we're working
season so
um i was i was told when i met with
scott
gimple um i was told that they were
getting
back to the trying to get back closer to
the comics
um because they'd gone
really far in season three i guess and
you know with
with killing off some some major um
players who were actually still alive up
until recently in the comics
and uh so the idea and the feel of it
and everything behind it was that they
wanted to
get back to the comics but i knew in the
comics you know after doing the research
on that that he only
was around for you know
20 or 30 uh publications
um i used to know the numbers he came in
in like
uh
i forget what it was but i feel like he
was in it at 30
something and and died at 90 something
um well you read all of those you
actually read all of them i did i read i
read up until
his uh breathing till his passing and
then a little a little a little beyonce
gets
really sucked into it um and
so i knew it was it was great you know
there was there was a bunch that had
changed from the
from the graphic novels to the the show
it's interesting that the
the daryl character um
changed how a lot of the other
characters were dealt with because what
what kirkman had done
in the graphic novel was he would bring
in characters who would become
confidants with rick and sort of
sort of like his new best friend uh not
to sort of trivialize
that you know his writing but um but
that that's the
the the mechanism they served someone
who would get close to him
and we could learn more about him uh
through the people that he met
you know and it was same thing with
tyrese when he met tyrese he very very
close
shared a lot and through the sharing you
learned a lot about him that he got
killed off and that you know then my
character comes in
um so having the daryl character there
who is his true
best friend and confidant the whole time
changed the dynamic of how those
those characters when they did come in
how they functioned in the world so
um i knew that my time would be
sort of similar to what was in the comic
um it didn't really matter
you know fans loved it or hated it you
know kirkman said early on you know the
way we think that we show this world is
a dangerous world is we we kill people
we love
so you know i knew that i wasn't you
know
when did they tell you michael wasn't
rick it wasn't daryl you know it wasn't
that wasn't well what did they tell you
when did they didn't do a pull up
i interviewed this guy chris jericho big
wrestler and he said
that he knew that he was gonna win the
championship that day
they told him so did they give you like
a week a week ahead they go hey
did they call you what was the real i
got a call when i was in
uh in new york um
i think there's a break between between
we shoot our seasons in two parts the
first
first part in the second part there's a
week break in between sort of the
hottest time
in georgia the crew has already gone
through eight episodes
everybody's just dead it's it's brutal
it's august
um and so we take a week two weeks off
uh
in in august and uh then we come back
and finish the rest of the season
and during that time i i i ran out to
new york
and i get a phone call from
uh from scott he's like hey uh he leaves
me a message hey
uh you're dead no i take it back
the a.d called the a d call
matt goodwin called he's like hey uh
scott wants to set up a
a call with you for next week
okay did you say why i would have been
like why who do you know
it's like do you know what it's about
he's like no no it's just a
you know second so you sort of like
where everything's headed
okay all right sure next wednesday
two o'clock sounds great so then i
immediately called scott i'm like hey
uh call me back
because i'm like hey what's going on i
go you can't do that
you can't be like oh hey i said if
you're going to kill me kill me i want
to know i don't want to be wondering
like i'd rather start processing me
being dead now then
then wonder if i'm going to be dead for
another week and a half
and then have to process it i said it
doesn't matter you're already like i
already assume i'm dead
so either confirm or deny and he said
well
i said okay so yeah so i'm dead well no
i mean i don't i go
yes it's okay um so we talked about this
when i first came in i wasn't
uh i wasn't upset per se um
i wasn't happy to leave the show you
know i would have
liked to have continued if that wasn't
in the cards
uh but i wasn't i wasn't really bummed
out about it because i knew it was
coming so
uh ultimately i i wish we had done a few
more episodes with myself and siniqua
uh when you know when all out war
happened because it would have been nice
to actually see
abraham functioning as a soldier um
but that wasn't in the cards and that's
you know we have to make room for
you know characters we love die so new
characters can come in that we can fall
in love with